what's the vibe today when when you're
getting ready and you're you're like
getting in the headspace to perform on
the oscar stage
um oh my god i was nervous
not sucking
i mean that's kind of my mindset doing
anything but especially at the oscars
um yeah i think i'm gonna just try not
to suck and like be the best that i can
and i'm i'm really excited this is a
song that i genuinely
like adore to be honest and i don't know
if that's cocky but i love i love this
song we created i feel really proud of
it and
i love to perform it so i'm excited
there's a magic about bond songs that
you have to live up to where you're
nervous about living up to that
standard and let's get your mom in
get your mom in here get your mom's
coming come on over yes come here mom
but yes the answer is yes i mean it's
such a
like it's it's it's an enormous amount
of pressure but not like you know
somebody was like this is a big thing
that you have to it was only in
ourselves that we put that pressure on
us because
bond has meant so much to us for so long
that like we needed to live up to it or
else you know
let me ask you because your mom's here
twin flames today in your sustainable
gowns yes tell us about them
well my dress is i'm partnering with red
carpet green dress i have a sustainable
gown by
benedetti live with ten south africa
billy's wearing all kind of vintage
jewelry yes we have a lot of things
going on to promote sustainability and
fashion much fun is to share this moment
with your kids
it's unbelievable i'm so happy she's on
the carpet my husband is here too
this is a family affair today
you know what just yeah asking you know
sharing this moment but like seeing what
your kids are doing
when they come to you and say we're
creatives we're going to be singers
we're going to be songwriters they're
like okay
i don't know all felt very natural but i
never would have in my wildest dreams
really imagined it would
you know end up the way it has
not that they didn't deserve it did i
hear you say you you're wearing gucci
this is a gucci
both of you in gucci large um
what was i going to say i don't know
what i was going to say i want it
because it looks comfortable very
comfortable very nice
quick um i want to ask you about taylor
hawkins
i mean what a what a legendary performer
and you know somebody we were inspired
by and fans of long before we got a
chance to know him and yeah we only met
him a couple times i wish we'd gotten a
chance to know him even better but um
yeah we're devastated devastated you
know just in the short time of meeting
him a few times it felt like you know we
lost a friend and uh such a genuine kind
like generous dude sometimes people are
are so generous with their energy that
they give you and they're they're just
like the shortest moment when somebody
can feel like a really big moment really
just such a sweet guy and we just you
know it's my heart breaks for his family
and his friends and everybody in the
band
yeah it's heartbreaking
get on stage and do the damn thing
tonight okay
thanks guys
you